I hold the power of life and death over
all of you how do you know so much man I
know you Caitlin Cisco Joe Wally to say
well I know your fears I know your
weaknesses I know you better than you
know yourselves I know your Destiny's
one shall betray you one shall fall one
will suffer are these four words and
death this is the knowledge I have of
you hey everybody its charlie
I know sabotage prophecy makes things
sound very dire for Team flash the
future is that you can't change it but
we know that they've been trying to
change it the last couple of episodes
with a small amount of success so if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything there's
going to be all kinds of flash stuff
happening this year in addition to all
the Marvel movie stuff and the DC stuff
there's even an injustice to giveaway
going on that I'll explain at the end of
the video but this is going to be all
about one important aspect of that
Sabbat our prophecy the betrayal how
does he get back from the Speed Force
and careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up on the flash but the Speed
Force
that seems like we're sabot are is stuck
right now the only way for him to exit
it and enter our world is the
Philosopher's Stone in there are two big
parts to this including Caitlin stuff
and Wally stuff so the Caitlin stuff
first
then I'll address the Wally stuff we
know the stone was thrown into the Speed
Force so it should be lost there should
be no way force avatar to get back yet
Barry travelled into the future in the
whole back half of the season is being
dedicated to finding a way to save iris
[Music]
now Barry
meaning that he has to get back somehow
and it sounds like a sabotage said in
his prophecy one will betray you but who
is that person will the producers of T's
some new information that might imply
who that is and how that might play out
so the first important thing what do we
know about the philosopher's stone is
that Julian has a strong connection to
it he's very susceptible to sabotage
mental attacks he doesn't have to be in
our world to control Julian and for him
to become the doctor alchemy persona as
we saw Salvatore uses him as something
of a finger puppet
so a big part of his redemptive arc is
in trying to make right the things that
he did while he was alchemy he's very
sad felt like he was weak could not
withstand savat our meaning that he
could probably fall under his spell
again now he's on Team flash it seems
like he's adjusting to social life even
though he's delightfully awkward says
all the wrong things at all the right
times but Caitlin is now starting to
enter his life in a more personal way
you have to imagine that inviting him
out for drinks is leading to something
more and whether or not they pursue a
relationship there is one thing that
Caitlin wants to do more than anything
else and that is get rid of her powers
you
[Music]
it is completely dominated her art this
season so what the producers have said
is that Caitlin gets the bright idea
that if alchemy can give people powers
if they had them during flashpoint he
might be able to take them back
so sabotage the Philosopher's Stone dr.
alchemy all things the Julian wants to
stay away from at any cost so she is
going to have to push to get him there
but it sounds like she's going to try
and coerce him to become dr. alchemy
again to try and get rid of her powers
but in order to do that you would need
the Philosopher's Stone I don't think
you're weak because of what happened to
you without it are the strength that I
found to stay in control that came from
you so thank you so it's entirely
possible that alchemy wanting to atone
for the terrible things that he's done
as alchemy wants to help Caitlin but in
doing so retrieves the Philosopher's
Stone giving savat are a conduit to get
back to our earth because right now the
Philosopher's Stone is stuck in the
speedforce this nexus of space-time so
until someone tracks it down again sava
tar is held at bay because they couldn't
even communicate with Savitt are in the
way they did with Julian in episode 9
without the philosopher's stone so they
couldn't even do that without him the
second big part of this is Wally he got
his powers via the Philosopher's Stone
so anything that Caitlin tries to do
with the stone in alchemy will involve
Wally somehow
take your power well don't worry
[Music]
he liked the other metas that were
created with the stone have dreams hear
voices from sabotage so he is still weak
to mental attacks that might become a
thing later in this season and if the
stone comes back that means as a
speedster he also has the ability to
helps avatar enter our world because he
needs these are a conduit or someone
with the stone but the stone is stuck in
the speedforce
the only way to get it out the only way
to enter the speedforce is either with
Cisco or have a speedster who's willing
to help you
why what is it not to open the door I
can do that why I can't sew with Wally
were to go crazy town banana pants like
he did when Sava tar was calling to him
the first time he could become a huge
liability for the team in the same way
that Caitlin's becoming a huge liability
trying to get rid of her powers you see
this team emerging with all the members
of team flesh each of them has their own
problems they're dealing with this
season some of them see more dire than
others iris know she's going to die
Caitlin know she'll eventually become
killer frost while they can't stop
hearing Savitt are voices in his head
it's driving him mad so they tied it up
really nicely with episode 12 for that
we need to do this together that was the
big message of that episode but like all
problems sometimes it just gets so bad
like you see Wally here getting ready to
punch iris in the face that was one of
the most funniest most WTF moments from
that episode
while he's out of work so the swing at
iris West got knocked the hell out just
shows you the crazy links that they will
go to to make themselves feel better to
relieve their pain so I always get a lot
of questions about the mistakes the
characters make Caitlin's a good example
why would Caitlin want to bring the
philosopher's stone back if that meant
that Salvatore could come back just to
get rid of her powers well sometimes
what happens is is the show just doesn't
do a good job of showing you the kind of
pain that they're in like she is in
agony right now it's like she's walking
around on the street with a giant ice
piano hovering above her just getting
ready to drop at any second and she's
going to do anything she can to get rid
of that so when something like that
happens nobody thinks clearly which is
also how Barry makes mistakes you can
really explain any of the mistakes that
the characters make that seem very
illogical given what they did last
season well here's the world's foremost
specialist on metahumans this is legit
truth and I need you to help me get rid
of my powers I've tried everything I've
run every test blood DNA and I can't
reverse this I need to get rid of my
powers before this one
before I hurt someone else so the bad
thing is always keeping secrets not
telling the other members of the group
how much they're hurting but even if
they don't explain it very well on the
TV show what they're trying to do is
just show you very human characters
trying to deal with these new super
powers even barre is still pretty fresh
as the flash this is only his third year
with his powers so you have to imagine
that comic book Barry Allen has had his
powers for 10 plus years for a long time
so let me know in the comments which
member of the group do you think is
going to crack first and do something
that will give Salvatore a direct route
to getting back into the real world
where he can kill iris or don't forget
the Flash's back next week there'll be a
new episode tomorrow I'll be doing new
Game of Thrones new Walking Dead then
they'll be some more Logan Deadpool
follow-up so I'll post updates on
Twitter and Facebook of what the
schedule is there's a new round of the
injustice to giveaway going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a flash related comment on
this video congratulations to last
week's winner
Wyatt Phillips please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys in
the next video while you wait for that
you can click here for my non-spoilery
Logan review and you can click here for
the trailer for the next episode of the
flash
you